madrid mar y madrid jucumari madrid y
jucumari
más de uno habrá pensado que estoy
delirando hablando alguna incoherencia
hablando en algún otro idioma
de hecho no solo ustedes hace un par de
días le pedí a un grupo de estudiantes
que me pusieran en un papelito que
entendían por estas palabras y me
pusieron desde que les sonaba una comida
tailandesa a una fruta exótica a una
serpiente y no sé qué cosas más pero
para mí son dos palabras sumamente
importantes ya que marcan el inicio de
mi historia con la fotografía la persona
a la que me ido convirtiendo y por qué
estoy acá
madrid- es el nombre con el que se llama
a un tipo de hormiga en una lengua
nativa llamada atacan a es el nombre de
un río es el nombre que un amigo
indígena le puso a su hija es un parque
nacional pero madrid y es mucho más que
eso es el área natural con la mayor
diversidad de especies vivas del planeta
y se encuentra aquí en bolivia
por otro lado jucumari es una palabra de
origen aimara que significa ser de las
profundidades y es el nombre con el que
comúnmente se llama en la cultura andina
a la única especie de osos que hay en
sudamérica pero qué tiene que ver todo
esto con la fotografía en el 2004 yo era
activista voluntario en una ong y tuve
que hacer un viaje a un pueblito en el
norte de la paz que se llama apolo que
es una de las entradas al madrid y había
ido para participar en una reunión de
comunidades ya que había la amenaza de
construcción de una carretera y fue ahí
que conocí a un joven que me dijo que
había un lugar donde se podía ver osos
jucumari
no sé qué hice no sé cómo lo convencí
para que me llevara a ver los preparamos
un par de cosas porque la caminata
podría ser 10 12 días según lo que me
había dicho pero para mi suerte al
segundo día después de haber cambiado
unas 3 horas en la selva llegamos a unas
tres tipos matorrales no había espacio y
llegamos a una especie de claro y cuando
levanté la vista al no más de diez
metros al frente mío mirándome fijamente
una madre cucu mar y con su cría
me quedé
totalmente paralizado empecé a sentir un
hormigueo por todo el cuerpo el corazón
estaba un punto las manos me temblaban
no era porque tuvieran miedo sino que
estaba presenciando una de las cosas más
lindas que había visto en mi vida fue un
momento muy especial empecé a analizar
el entorno la composición de esa escena
la luz que dibujaba ese lugar fue un
momento de total revelación sentí como
mi alma se conectó con todo ese entorno
sentí esa energía cósmica a la que
muchos pueden decirle dios estuve así 34
minutos no sé hasta que finalmente se
dieron la vuelta y se metieron
nuevamente en la selva
llega la paz muy emocionado a contar a
mis amigos de mi experiencia y nadie me
creía que la verdad que es muy raro que
te pases yo sé de muchos investigadores
que han estado meses buscando estos osos
y no han tenido éxito
se imaginan ustedes que diferente
hubiera sido que les cuente esta
historia con una fotografía y no con
esos recuerdos borrosos detalles y
emociones que olvidando con el tiempo
ese fue el motivo por el que decidí
comprar mi primer cámara fotográfica una
arroyos que conseguí de segunda mano con
ella empecé a explorar mi ciudad y
empecé a retratar a mis amigos a mis
familiares
cuando ya tenía una buena cantidad de
rollos mío fue una casa de revelado
es tuve que esperar como dos días muy
entusiasmado para que me entreguen las
impresiones y hoy ha querido que vean mi
cara de desilusión cuando estuve frente
a mí todas pero todas era una
algunas estaban blancas otras sabían que
estaban oscuras habían fotos
desenfocadas movidas y las que más o
menos se salvaba eran fotos que no
transmitían absolutamente nada decidí
pasar mi primer curso de fotografía ahí
aprendí con cuestiones técnicas aprendí
a manejar la cámara aprendí a revelar en
un cuarto oscuro pero pese a eso mis
imágenes todavía no transmitían lo que
yo quería como que no había algo que las
diferencias algo que las haga únicas les
faltaba algo era algo no sé qué es
con el tiempo mente se a obsesionar un
poco por encontrar la respuesta eso sí y
pasando más cursos empecé a hacer viajes
para hacer fotografías
de compra una mejor cámara me compré
lentes me llene de accesorios y mis
fotos sigan igual
con el tiempo empecé a entender que
habían otros elementos que eran mucho
más allá de saber manejar un equipo me
entró una obsesión muy grande por
descubrir que era decir no sé qué de
hecho muchas noches yo no dormía
pensando como esos fotógrafos que veía
en la national geographic así en esas
imágenes únicas tan especiales y fue
hasta que en algún momento empecé a
revisar el trabajo de grandes maestros
de la fotografía empecé a leer mucho
sobre sus vidas a ver qué tips qué
consejos te daban y empecé a implementar
eso en mis fotografías con el tiempo
empecé a encontrar una serie de
ingredientes que era muy recurrente en
sus trabajos y que me iban poquito a
poquito encaminando empecé a tener las
fotos que yo buscaba y finalmente
descubrí que era ese no sé qué es
una de las primeras cosas que me di
cuenta es que lo más importante no es la
cámara que tengas puedes estar con una
cámara súper profesional de miles de
dólares puede estar con tu teléfono
móvil pero
lo más importante es el ojo de hecho
muchos de los trabajos más lindos que he
visto los que más han impactado son con
cámaras que no son más grandes la que yo
tengo habitan acá
así que la próxima vez que vean
fotografías bonitas de algún amigo
fotógrafo no se les ocurra estar
diciéndoles que buenas fotos debe tener
una cámara buenísima no o acaso van a un
restaurante lo llaman al chef y le dicen
que comida más exquisita debes tener una
cocina espectacular no igualitaria esta
le dicen que melodías más buenas debes
tener una guitarra de lujo no la mirada
es lo más importante
otra cosa que me marcó bastante es este
concepto que se llama el instante
decisivo
esta es una imagen que hizo un
estudiante de mis cursos
roberto ruiz que me imagino que para él
esta imagen debe ser invaluable pero yo
también me siento muy conectados
me pongo en el lugar de él esperando su
hijo están en el quirófano él tuvo que
anticiparse tuvo que ver el lugar tuvo
que ver la luz tuvo que pensar dónde va
a ser mejor ángulo y qué instante iba a
ser el más importante entonces cuando el
médico y aseguró decía ya viene ya viene
ya viene él se fue se colocó
prácticamente al lado de su esposa hizo
esa imagen me recuerda mucho a la escena
de re león cuando levantan la cima
entonces el instante decisivo implica
tener que anticiparte a esos momentos
importantes en el flujo constante de la
vida y capturarlo en una fracción de
segundo
otra cosa que descubrí fue que existe
algo que se llama lenguaje fotográfico
que ven en esta imagen
estoy seguro que cada uno de ustedes ha
tenido una preciso percepción diferente
ha visto algunos detalles otros han
visto otras cositas pero permite es una
imagen que representa muy bien a lo que
es la sociedad paceña donde podemos ver
una vida un día cotidiano personas de
diferentes culturas de diferentes clases
sociales pero que tarde o temprano
tenemos que converger en alguna esquina
mirarnos cara a cara y darnos cuenta que
no somos tan diferentes los unos de los
otros
la fotografía tiene un lenguaje propio
tiene su propia gramática tiene su
propio vocabulario y como fotógrafos
tenemos que entender eso podemos
utilizar la fotografía como un espejo
para retratar tal cual es la realidad
donde lo más importante lo que tienes
delante pero también lo pudo utilizar
como un lápiz para moldear esa realidad
y poder plasmar ideas pensamientos y
emociones
otra cosa que es muy importante es hacer
imágenes que te interesen
cuando estaba pensando como les puedo
explicar esto me acordé de un amigo un
médico traumatólogo que empezó a subir
fotos de flores a su facebook así que
agarré lo llamé y le dije álvaro
porque flores
y su respuesta fue muy interesante y se
las quiero compartir desde un inicio
pienso pensé que la fotografía es un
ampliar el estado de conciencia ahora
generalmente uno cuando
peor si uno no es romántico pasas al
lado de una flor y no le dan ni bola no
te interesa a máximo sheraton qué lindo
sí pero de ahí a que te tomes el tiempo
la tenga las fotografías la observes
admires
lo divino en ella la existencia de lo
divino en ella creo que
creo que va por ahí
entonces que me quedo con esto
si fotografiamos solamente las cosas
porque así es bonita porque ese arbolito
representa el paisaje solamente vamos a
estar mostrando lo superficial de las
cosas si queremos comunicar tenemos que
escarbar por debajo de las cosas
otra cosa que es muy importante es que
si no vives emociones probablemente no
harás fotografías eso implica que con
fotógrafo tenemos que salir a
aventurarnos tenemos que salir de
nuestra zona de confort tenemos que
romper con nuestras barreras tenemos que
salir a caminar por nuestros barrios
buscar nuevas experiencias conocer
nuevas personas y la única forma que
nosotros podamos abrir nuestra mente y
de esa forma empecemos a ver las cosas
de manera diferente y empecemos a
percibir detalles que antes estaban
delante de nosotros pero no nos
admirábamos puede ser difícil puede ser
cansador puede ser agotador no esta vez
que me tuve que ir a escalar yo les
aseguro que vale la pena
tenemos que proponernos algo que tenga
consecuencias tener objetivos es lo que
en fotografía se llama proyecto
fotográfico como para roberto puede ser
un proyecto fotográfico documentar la
vida de su hijo de las esposas para
muchas personas puede ser otro tipo de
cosas a mí me llama mucho la atención
por ejemplo según el año pasado un grupo
de estudiantes cuyas profesiones nada
tienen que ver con la fotografía que
tienen muchas responsabilidades
familiares decidieron ir a un pueblito
en chuquisaca que se llama rosario del
ingre a documentar la fiesta patronal
una vez allí nos enamoramos de la gente
nos enamoramos de la cultura de la
riqueza patrimonial que tienen ahí y un
año después ellos siguen trabajando y de
hecho están volviendo dentro de poco
tiempo
tenemos que implicarnos emocionalmente y
ser autores de la historia
nadie puede contar tus historias tú eres
el protagonista tú eres el autor
de todos los medios y vos la fotografía
es el único que te permite capturar un
instante y guardarlos fotografiamos
cosas que se desvanecen que desaparecen
y cuando desaparecen no las podemos
revivir nunca
tenemos que dejar de llenar nuestros
ordenadores de miles de fotografías
banales y las vamos a volver a ver y
conservar sólo las fotos que realmente
importan y estar atentos a todos los
momentos
he pasado mucho tiempo buscando una
respuesta a que era ese no sé qué
y saben que había tenido frente a mí
hace mucho tiempo el día que me topé con
esa madre jucumari y su cría
si bien no pude hacer la fotografía mi
cerebro guardó esa imagen pero con el
tiempo se fue borrando años después tuve
una experiencia muy parecida me topé con
la madre y una cría de mono araña si
pude hacer un clic
si puede retener ese momento y de hecho
ahorita que estoy viendo esa foto me
emociono la misma para que ese momento y
se me viene a la mente todo lo que
rodeaba esa escena
qué es ese no sé qué y no lo pudo decir
mejor el maestro de la fotografía
enrique tiene razón
hacer una buena fotografía es retener el
aliento alinear la mente la mirada y el
corazón en un mismo eje muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah